[Música]
en Estados Unidos el gobernador del
estado de Texas grecabót anunció nuevas
medidas de control en la frontera Sur
ante el fin inminente del título 42
540 guardias nacionales eran desplegados
y contarán con apoyo aéreo y fluvial
la provincia canadiense de Alberta
siguen máxima alerta por los casi 100
juegos activos en la región de ellos 27
se encuentran fuera de control según las
autoridades la situación ha provocado
una caída en la producción petrolera del
país norteamericano
tras la victoria de la ultraderecha en
el proceso Constituyente chileno el
presidente Gabriel boric les pidió
actuar con sabiduría y templanza junto a
la derecha tradicional obtienen más de
los 30 escaños para aprobar una nueva
constitución sin pactar con la izquierda
un fuerte revés para el gobierno de
borics
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos el Informativo
en la frontera que une a Estados Unidos
con México en donde continúan los
movimientos a pocos días de la
expiración del llamado título 42 la
medida que permite deportar migrantes
argumentando motivos de salud pública el
gobernador de Texas gregabot anunció el
despliegue de una fuerza especial para
evitar el ingreso de personas
indocumentadas a Estados Unidos del otro
lado la esperanza de quienes aspiran a
pisar suelo de la Unión Americana es
avanzar antes de que rijan las nuevas
normas que implican más burocracia y
tiempos de espera
se acerca el final del título 42 el cual
aspirará este 11 de mayo y en Estados
Unidos se preparan para la nueva etapa
buscando alternativas para aplacar el
flujo migratorio en la frontera Sur en
el caso del gobernador de Texas la
decisión pasa por robustecer la
seguridad fronteriza con la presencia de
oficiales el Estado Sureño desplegará
otros 540 guardias nacionales y
helicópteros Black Hawk para repeler a
los migrantes irregulares
Texas está haciendo más que cualquier
estado en la historia de los Estados
Unidos de América para defender nuestra
frontera esto incluye desplegar hasta
10.000 miembros de la guardia nacional y
1.200 Soldados del departamento de
seguridad pública de Texas
la contracara son las personas que
buscan pasar la frontera antes del
jueves día en el que empezará a regir el
título 8 que tiene castigos más severos
para quienes entren irregularmente a
Estados Unidos la esperanza es avanzar y
evitar la burocracia de las próximas
medidas Claro si cambian las no te iba a
durar cuatro o cinco un año como lo han
hecho estos compatriotas que vienen
atrás de nosotros Y entonces nosotros no
querían eso para nosotros que no no que
arriesgarnos si pasaban los fines sino
bueno el gobierno de anunció que se
implementarán nuevos procedimientos para
entrar al país como la instalación de
centros de procesamiento regionales o la
ampliación del programa de reunificación
familiar con el objetivo de evitar los
viajes a lo largo del continente entre
tanto también en Texas el hombre que
atropelló a unos migrantes venezolanos
que esperaban en una parada de autobús
fue procesado por ocho cargos de
homicidio involuntario y diez cargos de
asalto agravado con un Arma Mortal
aunque las primeras investigaciones
apuntan a que el sospechoso perdió el
control de su vehículo las autoridades
no descartan que se haya tratado de una
acción intencionada
acusado de homicidio involuntario George
Álvarez es el hombre que atropelló con
su automóvil y causó la muerte de ocho
personas que esperaban el autobús al
frente de un centro de inmigrantes en
bro Texas avanzan las pesquisas para
determinar si el conductor embistió a
propósito
hay una investigación masiva en curso
para identificar exactamente lo que
sucedió Y esperan que salga información
donde puedan contarle al público mucho
más sobre lo que pasó si fue intencional
o no
las circunstancias del conductor y
seguir trabajando con respecto a las
víctimas
las primeras investigaciones apuntan a
que Álvarez perdió el control de su
vehículo al no respetar una señal de
tránsito Álvarez Fue presentado ante la
Corte y se ordenó su detención con una
fianza de más de 3 millones de dólares
dada su extensa historia criminal en un
comunicado el gobierno de Venezuela
pidió a las autoridades que investiguen
el incidente Venezuela exhorta las
autoridades estadounidenses
correspondientes a investigar en
profundidad los hechos y esclarecer sus
causas con el fin de descartar cualquier
intencionalidad relacionada a las
prácticas de odio y xenofobia contra el
pueblo venezolano que se han expresado
en el pasado uno de los migrantes que
vive en el centro mencionó que uno de
sus amigos hacía parte de las víctimas
nuestros compañeros lo que con los que
compartíamos las habitaciones o
cualquier conversaciones
echábamos puentes ubicado al norte de la
fronteriza ciudad mexicana de Matamoros
Brownsville ha visto un aumento de la
afluencia de migrantes en los últimos
días debido al inminente fin del título
nos vamos hasta Alberta en Canadá en
donde las autoridades confirmaron que
cerca de 100 focos de incendios siguen
activos actualmente y 27 de ellos se
encuentran fuera de control en lo que va
de año se han quemado 390.000 hectáreas
de terreno en esta provincia canadiense
que se encuentra en estado de emergencia
desde el sábado la situación ha
provocado una caída de más del 3% en la
producción diaria de crudo en ese país
el 80% del petróleo que se extrae se
saca de Alberta
Alberta continúa en estado de emergencia
provincial y los esfuerzos de respuesta
Aún se enfocan en proteger y apoyar a
sus habitantes durante estos incendios
forestales el centro de coordinación de
emergencias provincial continúa
coordinando la respuesta y permanece en
el nivel 4 que es el nivel más alto
ahora tienen 98 incendios forestales
activos Ardiendo en la provincia
vamos a México la suprema corte de
justicia invalidó una parte del llamado
Plan B la reforma al sistema electoral
impulsada por el gobierno de Andrés
Manuel López Obrador el tribunal Indicó
que se presentaron graves violaciones al
profesor legislativo puntualmente
declaró inconstitucionales las reformas
a la Ley General de comunicación social
y a la Ley General de responsabilidades
administrativas anteriormente nuestro
corresponsal en México Mario carbonell
nos contaba que caminos le quedan a
Obrador para aprobar su reformas
las reformas ya están aprobadas por el
congreso y ahora están siendo impugnadas
en la corte queda todavía el segundo
paquete la segunda parte que tiene que
ver con el adelgazamiento del INE del
Instituto Nacional electoral el
presidente López Obrador ha anticipado
que si la corte hecha abajo Todo el
paquete de reformas del llamado Plan B
él ya tiene un plan C Que consiste en
Llamar a votar todos a favor de su
partido y de su movimiento y ni un solo
voto a lo que él considera son
conservadores ese ha dicho es su plan c
en caso de que la corte tumbe todo este
conjunto de normas Pero además a la par
de este Plan B también sean reformado se
han sustituido los consejeros de este
instituto nacional electoral y ahora la
nueva presidenta de acuerdo con la
oposición pues es afín al régimen al
gobierno de López Obrador por lo que
también es una vía para llevar a cabo
los cambios que él está planteando a
pesar de este revés de la corte en Chile
las elecciones para elegir al nuevo
consejo Constituyente que deberá
redactar una nueva constitución
resultaron en duro revés para el
gobierno de Gabriel boric los
ultraderechistas liderados por José
Antonio kast fueron los más votados y si
se unieran con los derechistas de chile
seguro podrían llevar adelante el
proyecto sin necesidad de entablar
diálogo con la izquierda
una propuesta impulsada por la izquierda
pero que deja a la derecha en una
posición favorable
los resultados de las elecciones
celebradas en Chile el domingo marcaron
la superioridad de los conservadores un
escenario opuesto al de los comicios
anteriores el partido republicano se
quedó con 23 de los 50 escaños
disponibles 7 más que la facción
oficialista unidad para Chile Si se
juntan con la derecha de chile seguro
podrían decir la confección de la
Constitución sin pactar con los
izquierdistas el presidente Gabriel
boric felicitó a los ganadores pero les
pidió mesura el nombre del estado y el
pueblo de chile les invito a actuar con
sabiduría y con templanza el proceso
anterior
y debemos decirlo
fracasó entre otras cosas porque no
supimos escucharnos entre quienes
pensábamos distinto Franz 24 diálogo con
Néstor Aburto director de contenidos de
radio bío-bío que me explicó el panorama
que enfrentará el país transandino se va
a alinear esta derecha en el consejo
constitucional que parte el próximo seis
de junio con la derecha tradicional es
una de las grandes dudas porque
eventualmente podría existir una
posibilidad de que la derecha
tradicional pudiera pactar con algunos
sectores de la centro izquierda que son
pocos pero que podrían pactar y hacer un
solo bloque eso es lo que está en juego
a contar de las próximas semanas los 50
miembros del Consejo Constituyente
confeccionarán una nueva propuesta de
Constitución para el domingo 17 de
diciembre fecha en la que se votará un
plebiscito de salida donde la ciudadanía
decidirá se aprueba o rechaza el cambio
aquí las noticias sigan en France 24
[Música]